One of the busiest 24 hours of news in a long
time, so let's get right into it.
We had democratic
presidential debate number seven last night
and it was the most shameful one so far in
terms of the hosting and the anchoring done
yesterday by CNN.
Of course, as you probably now know, CNN on
Monday published this exclusive report about
how Bernie Sanders in 2018 supposedly told
Elizabeth Warren that a woman can't win the
presidency, and then there was the pretext
of that used to create drama during the debate
exactly as I predicted would be done and in
general we'll get to that.
But in general, CNN filled the debate with
baiting questions and split screens, trying
to get people to fight.
Basically nobody took the bait and that was
actually a good decision by the candidates.
They wasted time with these open ended questions
like what makes you qualified to be president,
which at this late stage of the game, just
weeks before the first votes are lame, worthless
West waste of time.
Questions.
CNN wrote a follow up questions in advance,
which makes sense to have, but the questions
ignored the candidates actual answers.
So the debate was filled with followup questions
from CNN that were complete nonsequitors completely
ignoring what the candidates were actually
saying.
Really embarrassing.
And the biggest example of this was when they
asked Bernie about when he supposedly told
Elizabeth Warren a woman couldn't win.
Bernie denied it.
And they go right to Elizabeth Warren saying,
how did you feel when Bernie said a woman
couldn't win?
Bernie just denied it.
And they skip over asking Elizabeth Warren.
Well, Bernie denies it.
Can you clarify?
Are you sure?
He said it was their context.
Nothing.
Look at this embarrassing moment from yesterday's
debate.
CNN reported yesterday that and Senator Sanders,
Senator Warren confirmed it, a statement that
in 2018 you told her that you did not believe
that a woman could win the election.
Why did you say that?
Well, as a matter of fact, I didn't say it.
Uh, and I don't want to waste a whole lot
of time on this because this is what Donald
Trump and maybe some of the media want.
Anybody knows me, knows that it's incomprehensible
that I would think that a woman can not be
president of the United States.
Go to YouTube today.
There's some video of that of me 30 years
ago talking about how a woman could become
president of the United States in 2015 I deferred.
In fact, the Senate award was a movement to
draft Senator Warren to run for president.
And you know what I said, stayed back.
Senator Warren decided not to run and I did.
I did run afterwards.
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote by 3
million votes.
How could anybody in a million years not believe
that a woman could become president of the
United States?
And let me be very clear if any of the women
on this stage or any of the men on this stage
win the nomination.
I hope that's not the case.
But if they are, you will do everything in
my power to make sure that they are elected
in order to the feet, the most dangerous president
in the history of our country.
So Senator Sanders, Senator Sanders, I do
want to be clear here, yours
saying that you never told Senator Warren
that a woman could not win the election.
That is correct.
Senator Warren, what did you think when Senator
Sandra Sanders told you a woman could not
win the election?
I disagreed.
Bernie says, I didn't say it.
Next question is, Hey Elizabeth, what did
you think of of uh, what did you think of
Bernie saying that this is not how you run
a debate and then afterwards they premised
a full question round on it going to other
people with the title on screen saying, what
do you say to people who think a woman can't
win the election?
It's like who nobody has admitted to saying
that Bernie just denied.
Having said that, it was almost a Saturday
night live parody of what a debate would look
like.
But unfortunately it was the actual debate.
Now, by the way, not to Pat myself on the
back, but word for word, I called, how this
would go down two days ago.
I tweeted on Monday prediction, when it comes
up tomorrow, Warren will refer to Bernie as
her friend and Bernie will say, of course
a woman can be president, but the moderators
will keep going.
Check out what Elizabeth Warren said.
I disagreed.
Bernie is my friend and I am not here to try
to fight with Bernie.
And then Bernie Sanders later getting the
opportunity to clarify and literally use the
words I tweeted on Monday.
Of course a woman can be president.
This is no big Pat on my back.
It's that obvious how it would go and with
what CNN would try to do with it, we could
anticipate how Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders would handle it.
Now on policy, there were some interesting
moments.
The candidates were asked, would you bring
all troops home from the middle East?
No one said yes.
And this tricked some people.
Elizabeth Warren said she would bring all
combat troops home.
That's playing coy with combat versus peacekeeping.
Okay.
And you have to understand that when I tweeted
about this last night, a few people wrote
back and said, no, Warren said she would bring
everybody home.
No, she said she would get combat troops out
of the region.
That is way of not really answering the question.
Bernie Sanders for example, a lot of people
thought, no, he, he said he would bring them
all home.
Bernie Sanders listed things that we would
be better off having troops do than be in
the middle East, but Bernie also didn't say
that they would all come, come home and this
is actually not shocking.
It would be unrealistic for a presidential
candidate who understands anything about geopolitics
to say every troop is coming home from the
middle East because the reality is some troops
are going to stay in some places in the middle
East, whether Bernie's president, whether
Warren's president, whether Biden's president
or whether Trump is reelected president.
That's just being realistic.
But if you listen to how they said it, none
of them said they're all coming home.
There was a discussion about healthcare costs.
Bernie was asked about the price of his plan
and he was asked multiple times, don't we
deserve to hear the price tag?
Bernie has given us the price tag and now
you can argue Bernie's price tag is wrong
if you want to.
That's a legitimate conversation to have,
but to continue to pretend that Bernie has
never addressed the cost of his plan.
Again, more of this staging by CNN, which
we'll have more about tomorrow, that was adversarial
to Bernie to save a lease.
They also focused on the cost of healthcare
without ever mentioning the cost of Wars or
military interventions, which is very typical
in these sort of establishment debates when
it comes to foreign policy.
Pete boot edge edge didn't have a particularly
good night.
Often his answers were very consultant like
in a way he would state what the problem is,
uh, in society or in the economy and say that
we must fix it.
And then his time was up that those aren't
solutions.
It's not policy to restate what the problem
is.
It's great that he understands the problem.
He sounded good doing it in his polished way,
but not a particularly good night for Pete.
Buddha, judge, the topic of free college came
up again and once again booted judge repeating
this thing about, I don't want the children
of rich people to go to school for free.
This is the wrong position.
If you have a system where everybody pays
in on the basis of their income in order to
fund a tuition free state schools, if the
rich are paying in, their kids should be able
to get it.
Otherwise the rich will start arguing.
We shouldn't have to pay into something that
we can't benefit from.
Remember, most of them are going to go to
private schools anyway.
Mayor Pete is just wrong on this.
Let them get their free tuition to a state
school if they want to go because they paid
in.
It's a policy disagreement and I think he's
flat wrong on it.
Lastly, Tom Stier actually didn't do bad billionaire.
Tom Stire bought his way into the debates.
I don't support him.
I don't think we need another billionaire
president.
I don't plan to vote for Tom Stier, but yesterday
he actually did.
Okay.
He brought up climate change a couple of times
when it went well.
Here's one clip of Tom Stier
does white climate is my number one priority
and I'm still shocked that I'm the only person
on this stage who will say this.
I would declare a state of emergency on day
one on climate.
I would, I would do it from the standpoint
of environmental justice and make sure we
go to the black and Brown communities where
you can't breathe the air or drink the water
that comes out of the tap safely.
But I also know this, we're going to create
millions of good paying union jobs across
this country.
It's going to be the biggest job program in
American history, so I know we have to do
it.
I know we can do it and I know that we can
do it in a way that makes us healthier, that
makes us better paid and is more just
Stire did better than Pete Buddha judge.
He did better than Amy Klobuchar, and in fact,
he did better than Joe Biden as well, who
was extraordinarily low energy yesterday,
and Biden probably benefited from not getting
as much speaking time if I recall as Elizabeth
Warren and as Bernie Sanders.
So who won the debate?
If you evaluate yesterday's debate from the
perspective of the average person, I believe
this was a defacto win for Biden.
This doesn't mean Biden did anything great.
Remember, the more Biden talks, the worse
it is for him.
But CNN did what we knew they would do.
They successfully pulled Warren and Bernie
into this story about whether or not Bernie
said a woman can't win.
They did an entire round of questions about
it on policy.
Warren did fine, Bernie did fine.
There was nothing new or surprising about
the policies they were advocating for.
They've been doing it for six prior debates
to yesterday, seventh debate, but low energy.
Biden was able, as I predicted, to just talk
about policy and even though he kind of bumbled
through it, it frames him as presidential.
And the net effect yesterday with Amy Klobuchar
being a non-factor, Tom Stire basically a
non-factor booted judge certainly didn't do
anything to claw his way back into this thing.
The de facto result is Biden gets another
couple of weeks now where he remains the front
runner with no major obvious blunder, despite
just not sounding good at all.
That is going to pull him out of first place.
I know that to you and I, we watched this
stuff closely.
Biden's seemed slow, confused at times, centrist
policies that don't appeal to me.
But if you think about this through the average
voters eyes, the muddled Bernie versus Warren
thing is not going to take Biden out of first
place.
In fact, it's going to perpetuate it.
And that was exactly the goal of the Bernie
smear that started on Monday.
So overall, a completely botched debate following
the predictable CNN playbook to a T, tell
me where I'm wrong.
Checkout some of the things I was tweeting
as the debate was going on last night at D,
Pacman, and tell me where you disagree.